um
hearing will not come back to order we
will now recognize our third panel mr
ronald welch is assistant attorney
general u s department of justice
pursuant to the rules uh would you
please rise to take the oath
do you solemnly swear or affirm that the
testimony you were about to give will be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
let the record indicate that uh the
witness answered the affirmative
uh
i've noticed note that you uh you've sat
patiently through all of the previous
testimony so not only do you understand
the red light green light but uh
you'll be the final witness
and i appreciate your patience and your
being here to hear everything that came
before you're now recognized
thank you very much mr chairman
and i would ask that my full statement
be included in the record without
objections are ordered
um mr chairman ranking member cummings
members of the committee
i'm very pleased to be here today to
discuss the justice department's
continuing efforts to respond to the
committee's subpoena concerning ongoing
criminal investigations on the southwest
border and pending indictments in the
u.s district court for the district of
arizona
i want to say at the outset that the
department is fully committed to working
with you in good faith to accommodate
the committee's legitimate oversight
interests we hope the committee will
similarly engage in good faith with the
department
in a manner that recognizes the
important confidentiality interests
presented when congressional oversight
involves open criminal investigations
it's difficult
when the interests and principle
principled exercise of the prerogatives
of the legislative and executive
branches come into potential conflict
the constitution envisions that the
branches will engage in a process of
cooperation and accommodation to avoid
such conflicts and we look forward to
engaging in that process with you
as the committee is aware many of the
subpoenaed documents concern an open
criminal investigation conducted by the
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
known as operation fast and furious
other subpoena documents concern the
open investigation
and pending prosecution regarding the
shooting death
of agent brian terry
let me just say here that the death of
agent terry was a tragic loss and the
justice department extends its deepest
sympathies to his family they testified
courageously here a moment ago
we were very pleased to hear on monday
of the committee's commitment
not to compromise the investigation into
agent terry's murder or the broader drug
gun trafficking investigation and we are
fully committed to bringing to justice
those who are responsible for agent
terry's death
the department recognizes the important
role of congressional oversight
including oversight of the department's
activities it's the policy of the
executive branch at the instruction of
the president to comply with
congressional requests for information
to the fullest extent consistent with
the constitutional and statutory
obligations of the executive branch at
the same time
attempts to conduct congressional
congressional oversight of ongoing
criminal investigations
are highly unusual and present serious
issues
as the department's office of legal
counsel under president reagan explained
in 1986 the policy of the executive
branch throughout our nation's history
has generally been to decline to provide
committees of congress with access to or
copies of open law enforcement files
except in extraordinary circumstances
the policy is designed to fulfill the
department's obligations to preserve the
independence integrity and effectiveness
of law enforcement investigations and
the criminal justice process generally
and i want to say this policy is
completely nonpartisan it has been
relied on by administrations of both
parties for decades
so in response to your subpoena
this department has been striving to
reconcile the two principles by
accommodating the committee's oversight
interests while protecting our
confidentiality interests
striking this balance can take time and
effort it is not the case that the
department is refusing to comply with
the department subpoena in fact we are
working diligently to satisfy the
committee's core oversight interests
without compromising the important
purposes underlying the department's
policy that i have described
the starting point for our approach is
an agreement by the department that this
committee has a legitimate oversight
interest in information shedding light
on the genesis and strategy of the fast
and furious operation
we have focused on identifying documents
responsive to those needs
we've already made a good deal of
information available in total the
department has physically produced more
than 675 pages of documents to the
committee made available more than 900
additional pages for review
in addition we've made one atf official
available for an interview with the
committee staff and we hope we will be
able to schedule more interviews in the
upcoming weeks
the committee has requested briefings on
specific topics and we have agreed to
provide those
the department has taken the
extraordinary step of retaining an
outside consultant
contractor at substantial cost to assist
us in building a database of the emails
of the 19 individuals at atf whom the
committee has indicated a primary
interest in
we have engaged in a search of great
magnitude uh to to ensure that we get
the documents that you have asked for to
the best of our ability
the um
individuals there are 19 selected user
accounts that you have focused on they
contain over 724 thousand emails and
attachments in addition the department
has collected thousands of doc documents
flagged to us by atf as potentially
responsive
over two dozen lawyers at atf in the
department are reviewing those documents
and we have been able to provide
documents to the committee each of the
last three working days yesterday monday
and the friday before
the department will not be able to make
available all of the documents
encompassed by the subpoena because of
the law enforcement confidentiality
interest that i have already identified
we cannot provide
certain core investigative and
prosecutorial documents but we will work
with the committee to identify and make
available documents responsive to your
core request
let me uh conclude by
emphasizing that the department
recognizes that congressional oversight
is an important
part of our system of government
at the same time congressional oversight
that implicates ongoing congressional
investigations presents sensitivities
not raised in ordinary cases
despite the unique challenges posed by
oversight of open criminal matters we
remain optimistic that the department
will be able to satisfy the committee's
core oversight interests while
safeguarding the integrity independence
and effectiveness of the department's
ongoing criminal investigations thank
you for inviting me to testify and i'd
be pleased to answer your questions
i certainly hope so
i recognize myself
sir
if you're going to count pages like this
it's discovery you should be ashamed of
yourself
the only thing that this says is eternal
use only not for dissemination outside
the atf
that's not discovery
that is saying that nothing within the
document requested under any
circumstances are we going to be shown
it doesn't take so long if you don't
spend your life redacting
the pages go on like this forever
you've given us black paper instead of
white paper you might as well have given
us a ream still in its original binder
how dare you make an opening statement
how dare you make an opening statement
of cooperation
we've had to subpoena again and again
you've
your representatives of a of this of
your organization of the executive
branch have discouraged witnesses from
coming forward
it has only been the courage of
whistleblowers like the ones you saw
here today that have caused us to have
more documents on this case than you
have ever suggested turning over and how
dare you talk about 900 pages all of
which were available on the internet
your first discovery that you ever
turned over you gave us already
available on a google search documents
only
so sir
what executive privilege are you
claiming sensitivity is not envisioned
on monday we held a hearing here and i
hope you had plenty of people watching
and if you didn't get it on youtube
not one witness not on direct or on
cross
talked in terms of the kind of unique
sensitivity instead they gave us case
law and cases involving justice
that say just the opposite of what
you're saying
sir
you heard from the family and you heard
from the whistleblowers
they have concerns about whether you're
charging everybody in brian terry's
murder
and yes i'm deeply concerned and we
promise to get to the bottom of it if
somebody wants to call that political
interference so be it you should be held
to a standard of why everybody including
the people
who lied by and lie those weapons why
they're not being charged if there's any
chance they can be properly linked to
his murder but let's move on
understand that's for the family
for this committee we're investigating
you your organization
the executive branch above the phoenix
office is who we're investigating we
want to know what felony stupid bad
judgment led to allowing this program at
the highest levels when you've got the
head of alcohol tobacco and fire
on
on basically his computer screen
watching these things don't tell me you
didn't know what it was doing
it appears to us
on this side of the island i believe on
the other side that you thought this was
a good idea
today are you prepared to tell us that
this program was in fact necessary and a
good idea and are you prepared to tell
us who authorized it who was the
greatest highest ranking person who
authorized any part of it
mr chairman uh you've raised a number of
issues let me try to address the last
ones first like who authorized this
program that was so felony stupid that
it got people killed
the attorney general has said that he
wants to get to the bottom of this
he has directed the office of the
inspector general at the justice
department to review
this matter in order to answer questions
like the ones and if that's the case
then why are we any burden at all isn't
every one of our requests consistent
with what the inspector general and the
attorney general should be looking at in
this case
i i don't know for a fact that
everything you've asked for is what
they're looking at i hope you came here
to answer questions like that
we're asking for things related to the
above the field
level almost exclusively our questions
are about
who authorized this why did it happen
why did it continue
our question to you today is
the president said he didn't authorize
it he said the attorney general didn't
authorize it he didn't say he didn't
know about it he said he didn't
authorize it
who at justice authorized this program
as i've said mr chairman at the office
of the inspector general who at justice
and if you know
i ask you to answer who do you know was
involved in the authorization of this
today do you know
do you know
well mr chairman if you'll permit me to
answer the question um we sent a letter
to chairman smith who asked a question
like that we pointed out that this
operation as with other law enforcement
operations originated in the uh atf's
phoenix office that's not authorization
who authorized it at the highest level
again mr chairman please if you'll do
you know who authorized it at the
highest level and don't answer phoenix
or tucson or any part of arizona if you
please well mr chairman it's difficult
to answer your questions if you won't
permit me to answer that i want the
answer to my question which was who here
in washington authorized we know who
looked at it on video we know who who
authorized it effectively at least by
acquisition acquiescence
who authorizes it justice
uh mr chairman i do not know the answer
to that question and the inspector
general is reviewing the matter
then we will have somebody back who does
the ranking member is recognized
mr weiss um
let me apologize for that
um
you don't deserve that
um perhaps somebody else in the
department does what is your role what's
your job i'm the assistant attorney
general for the office of legislative
affairs congressman and um these are not
the decisions that you make i think the
questions that he was just asking about
the chairman is asking about that's
correct
and um as i've said many times there's a
certain
level of integrity that we must maintain
in this committee
i see this committee is just lower than
a court
and um
i know and i've said it to the chairman
and i'll say it over and over again
you've got to go home to your family
you've got colleagues who are watching
this and for you to be
hollered at
and um
treat it that way i just think it's
unfair
and so on behalf of the committee i
apologize
with the gentleman yield
no i will not you i'm trying to talk to
the witness i didn't interrupt you
no and you didn't i didn't ideally say
as long as i get them into time hold the
time but the gentleman please note you
may apologize on behalf of something you
say i am not apologetic right you may
not apologize on behalf of the committee
thank you gentlemen
let me say this
i apologize
because we're better than that
we're better than that
and i do hope that we bring
the appropriate people who can answer
those questions
and even when they come they should not
be treated that way
on
april 13th he wrote to the committee to
explain
the extreme sensitivity of some of the
documents covered by your committee's
subpoena of your open law enforcement
biology explain that the subpoena quote
encompasses records that would identify
individuals who are assisting in the
investigation and sources and
investigative techniques that have not
yet been disclosed
but this is not all of the records right
and i assume that
it is just a small subset of subpoena
documents and that you can redact such
sensitive information is isn't that
correct that's correct congressman and
that's what we're trying to do
now i can understand the chairman
uh being
upset because i'd be upset but i
wouldn't treat you like that about
somebody submitting to me some black
pages can you explain that to me well
one thing i want to make clear
congressman is that the number of pages
that i cited in my testimony as having
been produced or made available does not
include such pages where those pages are
redacted it's part of a document it's
showing where there was law enforcement
sensitive information that we were
unable to provide but that is not
included in the total so and what were
the total pages that you submitted
um let's get to the exact numbers well
while your staff is assisting you on
that let me let me get on going
i i have to okay it was we have
physically produced more than 675 pages
of documents and made available
more than 900 additional pages for
review and i should say this production
is ongoing we have made documents
available and physically produced
documents in each of the last three
business days and i expect the document
production to continue and if the
purpose of our investigation is to
understand what occurred and who is
responsible do you think
that you'll be able to provide
sufficient documents to answer those
core questions without
disclosing a highly these highly
sensitive records i'm sorry congressman
could you in other words you said that
there's some some confidentiality issues
and i'm trying to get to and you said
that this bans certain policy spans over
various administrations wasn't just
democratic administrations republican
administrations i'm just asking you
is there a way that we can get what i've
often said and i've said it in before
the hearing that the chairman referred
to
uh the other day i said there's we need
to do two things we've got two things
going on here we trying to look to see
how far this thing went up but at the
same time we've got these criminal
prosecutions and i'm saying is there a
way that we can resolve those issues
and is that within your purview yes it
is and i believe that we can do so uh we
are doing that by providing documents
by briefing the committee by making
documents available
and by facilitating witness interviews
we share the committee's goal in getting
to the bottom of these questions and we
are assisting the committee at the same
time that the department itself has a
review by the office of the inspector
general now you're further explaining
that it is the public release of this
information that presents the most
risks uh to ongoing criminal
investigations and prosecutions you
stated and i quote disclosure of these
types of information
may present risk to individual safety in
the violent environment of firearms
trafficking activities disclosure may
also prematurely inform subjects and
targets about our investigation in a
manner that permits them to evade and
obstruct our prosecutorial efforts even
if we're not so upset about and i am
always concerned about prosecutions the
fact that somebody's life might be in
danger gives me great concern
uh because i see it living where i live
almost every day
so what is the tell me something what is
the can you give me a response to that
yes congressman some of these documents
identify cooperating witnesses
they identify confidential informants
they describe a strategy
as to specific cases uh
ongoing cases and and and revealing that
strategy could inform potential uh
targets of the investigation uh of law
enforcement activities and it seems
unwise you yourself ranking member
cummings
highlighted a number of ways in which
the committee investigation has already
um uh inadvertently
overstepped the line and for example
made public a sealed document so we're
concerned about this we really think
that if we work cooperatively
we can help the committee avoid such
missteps
help satisfy the committee's oversight
interests and get to the bottom of these
questions thank you very much time has
expired the gentleman from oklahoma is
recognized would you yield to me for 30
seconds absolutely
did you provide those documents you say
were released that were sealed
the documents you're saying were
prematurely released were they were they
provided by you under any kind of
request you know i i'm not certain if
you'll permit me to consult with my
staff i'll be able to give you that go
ahead
i got the answer mr chairman and the
answer is no those were not documents we
provided those were documents that your
investigators obtained and then made
public in spite of the court order that
they not be made public
so you're saying that
if we get documents that we have no idea
because you're not providing documents
that were responsible
yes mr chairman seems to me that you
should ask the justice department
whether sensitive documents should be
made public that particular document
related to a wiretap which is always a
sensitive law enforcement staff and if
the committee would consult with uh with
us we would uh help the committee if you
had given us those documents with
appropriate guidance they obviously
wouldn't have happened you didn't do it
you had plenty of time to do it i yield
back to the
gentleman thank you
as i try to follow through this this
whole day and try to process what's been
going on february the 4th
there's a letter that senator grassley
back and forth with you
stating the allegation the atf
sanctioned or otherwise knowingly
allowed the sale of assault weapons to
straw purchasers who transported them to
mexico as false
may the second
may the second
you wrote again to senator grassley
reiterating it remains our understanding
that atf's operation fast and furious
did not knowingly permit straw buyers to
take guns into mexico yet i just asked
some agents about that
and their statement was they think about
1500 weapons are still out there and
probably two to one of those are in
mexico it
would would you like to change your
statement at all on that or have any
anything that you would want to shift on
your previous statements from february
or may
thank you congressman the
statements that you referred to
um uh are
every let me say this every time the
justice department sends a letter to
congress it is true to the best of our
knowledge at the time that we send it
those particular statements
remain true for the technical reason
that the committee's report issued last
night described the straw purchasers
don't take guns to mexico and in any
event atf doesn't sanction or approve of
the transfer of weapons to mexico that's
obvious but atf did permit those
knowingly understanding they're headed
towards the border and that was well
known apparently among the phoenix
office and as we can tell going up the
food chain that these purchases were not
being purchased by someone out as we
were stated bear hunting
these were straw purchasers buying in
large quantities and headed towards
mexico so how can we make a statement
we're not sanctioning that but we're
also not interdicting we're not trying
to stop it either right so obviously
allegations from the atf agents you've
heard from today and from others
have given rise to serious questions
about
how atf conducted this operation and
that's why the attorney general
instituted an investigation and it's why
we're cooperating in these committees
was there any communication
with leadership in mexico
so that if these weapons showed up in
mexico we were actually doing the law
enforcement
process here to make sure they were both
aware that these guns might be headed
that way or that we had a working
relationship when arrests were made we
would cooperate with them dealing with
these arrests congressman i can't uh
from my position in the office of
legislative affairs i don't have
personal knowledge of the kind of
communication my understanding is that
in general there are close ties between
u.s law enforcement and mexican law
enforcement including on gun
investigations so as a general matter
the answer to your question is yes as to
specific cases i'm not in a position to
say so so we're not
are you saying
they were aware that this fast and
furious was going on and that guns were
headed their direction they were
involved in that process or there's just
we know their phone numbers and we
occasionally call each other this
specific program is what i'm talking
about congressman i'm not in a position
to answer that question with specificity
do you know who might be a good person
that we could contact to get that kind
of specific information the committee
has already interviewed one atf agent
and as i said we're prepared to make
other agents available
and these include high-ranking atf
officials
i would think that those individuals can
speak with specificity to the question
that you're asking terrific what other
office besides the phoenix office was
doing this type of program
congressman i'm not in a position to
answer i don't know the answer to that
question okay
do you know how many offices that doj
has a relationship with that were
informed about this operation as it was
ongoing that might be engaged
at least have a a not necessarily
approval but at least acknowledgement
this is going on just be aware the
phoenix office is tracking straw poll
tracking straw buyers and they're out
there there may be as many as 1 500 gun
just be aware of that do we know how
many other officers were our agencies
were aware of that are you saying
offices or agencies justice department
agencies with injustice yeah that has
relationship with i don't know there is
close communication among the various
u.s attorneys offices and the law
enforcement components um there are you
know cross-cutting meetings and and task
forces and so forth uh including osidep
but i can't speak with specificity as to
this operation okay thank you i yield
back thank the gentleman gentleman from
missouri mr clay
thank you mr chairman mr weiss from what
i can see the department of justice has
worked hard
to comply with the committee's very
large document request
not only have you gone to considerable
limps and cost
you work with the with majority
committee staff to prioritize documents
of great interest
you have briefed the committee not only
on your ongoing processing of documents
but on the case itself on top of
delivering many documents you have made
the most sensitive documents
available for review
by committee staff in ways
that protect the documents integrity
it seems to me that the department is
cooperating with the committee's
extraordinary requests
and i say extraordinary because not only
is the scope of the request very large
but because of his timing
during ongoing criminal investigations
as well as an ongoing inspect ig
investigation
flashing back to when the committee was
investigating blackwater
during the previous administration a
member of this committee
now in the majority
said that
quote
we are supposed to allow the
administration to do this investigation
and then we do oversight end of quote
now i believe we have a legitimate
interest in conducting oversight
of the administration but we should not
jeopardize ongoing criminal cut cases
or ig investigations
just because a different party
now holds the white house
mr weiss in your statement you explained
that the department has made
certain documents available to committee
staff
for their review
but without providing copies this is
because the documents contain
sensitive law enforcement material and
the department needs to prevent their
public disclosure
is this a common practice yes it's a
very common practice as i detail in my
written statement
for many years the department has used
this process of making documents
available in order to
maximize the number of documents that a
committee can have access to uh chairman
for many years have accepted this
practice
and we do it because the rules of the
house do not
easily permit a committee to keep
documents confidential
and indeed this committee has declined
to
provide any such assurances
so this is what we do we make documents
publicly
make documents available physically that
that we are prepared to see be made
public and those that are not we make
available to the committee investigators
and it's obvious it was very disturbing
to you and the department
that the
to the fact that despite your procedures
and clear warnings the majority and
senator grassley
has inappropriately released
sensitive document
let me say this congressman what i i
have as the chairman noted i've been
here all morning and i listened to
senator grassley as well as to the terry
family and to the atf agents who
testified
the common view of all the witnesses and
the members of the committee is that it
is vital that these prosecutions most
notably the prosecution of agent terry's
uh alleged killers be successful that we
not do anything to harm those
prosecutions our efforts to preserve
confidentiality of certain law
enforcement sensitive documents is in
furtherance of that goal and and and you
wrote uh on monday that you heard during
that you heard during the hearing on
monday that the committee is committed
to not compromising
the murder investigation or the broader
gun trafficking investigation through
its oversight activities given what
we found out about improper disclosures
and improper contact with witnesses and
the way that these hearings have been
structured and conducted
i'm not sure i agree with your
assessment i think that the majority's
actions have come very close
to compromising the investigations and
prosecution
if they already have not done so
do you still believe in the majority's
commitment to not compromise these
investigations
congressman clay we want to work with
the committee
we have an ongoing relationship with the
committee staff
i think it's important for us to
flag these warnings and and maintain
appropriate boundaries but uh we share
the committee's interest in getting to
the bottom of these allegations and so
we will work with the committee
i'm thankful
thank the gentleman we now recognize the
gentleman from utah mr chaffetz uh when
did you first talk to uh attorney
general holder about this issue
um as best as i can recall it came up in
preparation for uh his oversight
hearings in in may uh he was asked about
it i think by chairman isa do you still
hold tight to the so you're suggesting
that the uh the letters that you sent on
february 4th 2011 to senator grassley
and again another letter on may 2nd 2011
to senator grassley that the content of
that of those two letters is complete
and accurate as best you know
congressman i've said uh that's a yes or
no question is it complete accurate
congressman yes or no well respectfully
that's not susceptible to a yes no
answer
go ahead thank you um
as the committee's report pointed out
there is a technical explanation for why
uh the allegation that atf uh sanctioned
the sale of guns to straw purchasers who
then transported them to mexico
is not an accurate statement and so we
said that that was false however serious
allegations have come to light including
the testimony of the agents today that
cause attorney general holder to want
there to be an independent review of
this matter and he's initiated that
review so uh we're not clinging to the
statements in in those letters uh we're
saying so if i said that i think
somebody knowingly and willfully
actually misled and lied to congress
would i be off base
respectfully congressman you would be
in in that uh we make every effort to
provide truthful information to congress
i know that's something that i i would
like to highlight
on january 8th remember these these
letters came out in february 4th and may
2nd but on january 8th and i will quote
from this
internal document here from the phoenix
field division
that indicated on page four quote
currently our strategy is to allow the
transfer of firearms could to continue
to take place albeit at a much slower
pace in order to further the
investigation and allow for the
identification of co-conspirators who
would continue to operate and illegally
traffic firearms to mexican
drug trafficking organizations and it
goes on there the administration knew in
january before these letters came out
that it was on purpose
it would continue to operate and
illegally traffic firearms to mexico how
can that stand and how can you and the
department of justice and people who
take responsibility for this allow the
lies to continue to come to congress
why did this obama administration
purposely allow the illegal transfer of
more than 2 000 weapons that they knew
according to this memo we're going to go
to mexico
congressman you've asked questions that
the office of the inspector general is
looking at that this committee is
looking at and i want answers from you
that's why you're in that's why you're
here you have this document you know
that this is true this memo goes on to
continue to say and again in january to
date there have been five notable
seizure events connected with the group
approximately 53 firearms originally
purchased by this group have been
recovered three of these seizures have
been in the country of mexico we knew
that this was these were going south and
yet in your letter that you state quote
it remains the understanding our
understanding that atf's operation fast
and furious did not knowingly permit
straw purchase buyers to take guns into
mexico that is patently and totally
false
how do you do that how do you do when
this comes out in january and again in
may you write and you tell this congress
that they did not knowingly permit star
purchasers to take guns into mexico in
total contradiction of the memo of
january 8th how does that happen
congressman i've explained to you that
we do our best to provide the
information to congress as we know it as
allegations have come to light
we've initiated an investigation and
cooperating with this committee's
investigation
is fast and furious still ongoing
i i don't believe so congressman i'm at
what point did the attorney general uh
did he order it that would be taken down
did we stop doing it at what point did
they actually say all right enough is
enough the attorney general made very
clear as this uh matter came to light
that uh
guns should never be walked to mexico i
want to know when the attorney general
actually got engaged in this why didn't
he know about it when did he know about
it or is he just oblivious to it no a
congressman he answered
chairman ice's question on the house
judiciary committee
the question was uh but i questioned him
also on the house judiciary community if
you remember you were sitting in the row
right behind him and he said he didn't
know when he first knew about it so i'm
trying to figure out when did he know
about it and then what did he do about
it he he told congressman i said that he
first learned about it several weeks
before the hearing in connection with
press and what i don't understand is
when you go back and look at the record
president obama knew about it back in
march if the president knew about it why
did the attorney general know about it
and why are you issuing a memo uh
in may
when the president of the united states
in an interview with i believe univision
is saying we know that there were some
mistakes made
how does that happen the president makes
this comment and then still months later
you have the gall to issue a memo to
this congress saying that's just false
it's not true
that does not add up and that's what
this investigation is going to continue
to pursue yield back
i thank the gentleman
if i may grant myself time for a
colloquy because the gentleman does seem
to be rather upset
i've read the statement and
if you were to parse words and determine
the meaning of is
then you probably could say that
because the straw purchasers the
original buyers did not take them to
mexico but rather transferred them to
intermediaries that in fact they did not
knowingly take them into mexico i would
not call it the whole truth but i
certainly understand why if someone's
trying to deceive and mislead that they
could in fact write a letter like that
uh and uh and think that they
technically didn't lie and they would be
correct with that we recognize next the
gentleman
you haven't done yours we recognize the
gentleman from south carolina mr gowdy
thank you mr chairman um
sir i know that you were here this
morning while
the members of the committee were and i
will say this with all the civility that
i can muster i think it is bitterly
ironic
that you would refer to committee
missteps before you
refer to atf or doj missteps
in response to questioning from mr isa
you use the phrase committee missteps
i think the purpose of this hearing is
not so much
our
missteps real or perceived but the
missteps of atf and doj
so let me start by asking when did
anyone at doj know that firearms in
connection with this investigation were
going to mexico
congressman that's not a question that
i'm equipped to answer as i've said the
inspector general is looking at it and
we're cooperating in this committee's
investigation well
and let me i may just say congressman i
i didn't
start out my testimony by talking about
committing the steps i didn't talk about
it in my opening statement no sir you
did not but it is bitterly ironic that
the first criticism you would have or
the first use of the word overstep would
be of this committee and not of atf and
not of the united states attorney's
office in arizona and i frankly am
shocked at the relationship between atf
and that particular united states
attorney's office it is
untenable and unworkable and i would
hope that someone at doj
would ask some questions of the us
attorney's office in arizona i cannot
imagine that kind of working
relationship where proffers are not
allowed and subpoenas takes six weeks to
be approved
and
and i would be hopeful that you would
ask that so you do not know when do doj
knew that firearms are willing to mexico
no sir i personally do not all right
what is do oj's policy on guns walking
the attorney general has made very clear
that guns cannot walk to mexico that is
to say guns it is it is a per se uh uh
violation of law for guns to be
transported across the border to mexico
what is your definition of walking
that uh as as the committee's report
made clear is the subject of much
discussion within atf and uh i'm asking
about doj
i'm afraid i'm not in a position to
answer that question i will say um that
it is but you would agree that saying
that that me physically handing someone
who's a prohibited person a gun that
cannot be the only definition of walking
having knowledge that a gun is leaving
your area of surveillance or or
jurisdiction is walking correct
i i can't define walking what i can say
congressman is that it is
this is a challenging enforcement
environment as i think you know as a
former federal prosecutor yeah i i do
but but i also got to tell you as a
former federal prosecutor this is
unprecedented i i've never heard would
you ever allow or sanction control
substances if if it were control
substances and not firearms would you
have ever allowed or sanctioned or
permitted them to walk
first of all there's a big difference
drugs are per se illegal and guns are
not the sale of a firearm or multiple
firearms to an individual who is not a
prohibited person is not illegal of
course
i'm aware of that would you have allowed
controlled substances to skip
surveillance and go to mexico
that's a question that's well beyond my
area of responsibility or expertise i
will note that of course there are uh
controlled buys in narcotics cases in
order to uh
pursue
a drug conspiracy and pursue the highest
levels of a drug conspiracy
i know that from my personal experience
as a prosecutor
who can we ask who can we invite before
this committee that can tell us
definitively when the department of
justice
knew that guns were going into mexico
who would you invite us to
invite
i think you're
pursuing the right track if i can be so
presumptuous
you're you're obtaining documents you're
interviewing witnesses you interviewed
agent newell who's one of the
individuals mentioned in the testimony
today as having been very involved in
this there are other agents and atf
officials who we are ready to provide
for interviews what about what about the
united states attorney in arizona when
did the u.s attorney know the guns that
were part of this was an also death
investigation so it's impossible to
argue the united states attorney's
office wasn't part and parcel to it when
did the united states attorney in
arizona know that firearms were leaving
the united states and going to mexico i
don't know the answer to that question
congressman gowdy but could i just say i
know dennis burke
the u.s attorney there he is a very
hard-working dedicated public servant
and
what obviously happened here is there
was a serious profound disagreement
about strategy but the common goal of
the united states attorney's office and
all of the atf agents uh is to
interdict guns to to stop the gun
trafficking to mexico uh so uh mr burke
i'm sure uh was dedicated to that
purpose sir with respect given the fact
that you know mr burke and i do not
would you share with him what was said
this morning about the dissatisfaction
with federal law enforcement in arizona
and the relationship that they have with
the united states attorney's office
because that has not been my
experience certainly not in south
carolina not in other jurisdictions the
level of animosity and the fighting
between law enforcement and and federal
prosecutors over something as simple as
a proffer are you aware of any united
states attorney's office that doesn't
engage or or allow the use of profits
it's obviously a common technique
of course it is there's no way to build
a historical case without profits since
you know mr burke and i do not would you
ask him to do what he can to repair his
relationship with law enforcement
because it appears to be fractured from
this vantage point i'd be happy to talk
to him but i'm i'm sure he's monitoring
this here and closely thank you i thank
the gentleman we recognize the gentleman
from massachusetts mr lynch for five
minutes thank you mr chairman just
briefly uh following up on that point uh
it would seem that
the
the uh the approach of the at least the
deputy our assistant u.s attorney down
there was
to require corpus delecti the body of
the crime to actually have the guns in
order to proceed with the prosecution
that that will uh
if that's the if that's the case i
believe it's an improper application of
the law
and since this committee is is involved
in overseeing that our laws once passed
by congress are indeed enforced
uh
it would serve us all i think if we
review that the application of the law
if that indeed is the the approach of
the office down there um congressman
lynch if i may one thing that's been
brought to my attention is that the
united states attorney's office has
brought cases involving large numbers of
guns straw purchasers uh individuals
alleged to have uh traffic guns without
a license and that those prosecutions
have sometimes resulted in uh
hung juries or directed verdicts of
acquittal because of the high standard
of proof especially in the ninth circuit
so there may be something for congress
to look at in its legislative
arena as well okay uh with that i will
yield the balance of my time to the
gentleman from maryland mr cummings
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to
submit our
letter for the record requesting the
minority day of hearings
um
stated june 15th today
thank you i'm in receipt of your request
well i'm asking that to be admitted into
the record mr chairman
signed by the members of that
certainly without objection so order
thank you very much
i want to say this to you mr weiss um
and i'm sitting here and i'm listening
to all this and i want you to take a
message back
some kind of way we've got to establish
um
the
you know the majority has some concerns
and i think
many of them probably quite legitimate
and there has to be a balance here
i'm always concerned about people
possibly dying as a result of something
we might do in this committee
i'm concerned about murderers getting
off i've spent
a phenomenal amount of time trying to
protect witnesses i've submitted
legislation
that has been held up on
in the senate side
by the other side
trying to protect witnesses
i believe in ultimate cooperation
between
law enforcement and the city and public
i have a record of it for years
you know why because i go to the
funerals
i see the deaths
i hear the cries and i experience the
pain
and
some kind of way we've got to make sure
that we strike the balance that i was
just talking about and i'm not sure i'm
just not sure
whether that balance has been struck the
way it ought to be
this committee has a job to do
the justice department has a job to do
and some kind of way we've got to find a
way as the adults in all of this to make
that happen and make it work
and i'm very serious about that you
gotta you know life is short and i tell
my staff
that every day i look in the mirror and
i face my own mortality
and the question is
is what how can i be most effective and
efficient and when we go this do this
ring around the rosie stuff what happens
is is that none of us are effective
and you heard me make a commitment to
that lady miss tury
i shall not rest
until everybody involved in this process
and i mean that i shall not rest
until all of that is addressed now the
chairman said something was very
interesting
he uh a moment ago spoke about
all this transparency and we need to
read the whole document and i appreciate
that but the one thing he did not say
is on about this memo on january 5th he
didn't read this piece
uh you remember mr chavis
mentioned this memo so they wrote a read
a piece of the memo but they didn't read
all of it
and
let me just read this line so that the
record will be clear it says
investigative
talking about this january it's gen on
january 5th
2010 it says investigative and
prosecution and i quote investigative
and prosecution strategies were
discussed and a determination was made
that there was minimal evidence at this
time support to support any type of
prosecution i just wanted to finish that
because i think it's important
particularly in the light of the
chairman saying that we needed to have
the whole statement and with that i
yield back i thank the gentleman we now
go to the gentlelady from new york miss
burkel
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
white for being here today
uh i
i have a couple questions you keep
alluding to the the uh inquiry and the
investigation that ig is going to
conduct at the request of of uh
that office is currently conducting that
investigation all right so are you
concerned that their investigation is
going to conflict or interfere with
doj's investigation
that that's oh you mean the criminal
investigation yes the inspector general
has a good deal of experience in
avoiding those kinds of conflicts and of
course their work is strictly
confidential
any report that they would issue
publicly would be carefully vetted to
avoid those kinds of concerns
and so
you're not concerned that they will
interfere with the dog's investigation
just to be clear we are not concerned
okay
then why are you concerned that
congressional this this investigation
that's continually what we hear while
there's an ongoing investigation and so
we feel we're not getting the answers we
need because you're concerned about
compromising this other investigation so
i'd like you to differentiate for this
committee sure well first of all
congresswoman we're not saying that this
committee should not investigate to the
contrary we recognize the legitimate
oversight interest and we are
cooperating with the committee as it
pursues this so we're not in any way
saying don't do this but if i could
interrupt for a minute there's a de
facto if you don't if you don't provide
what's being asked or you provide what
we see here all those redacted sheets
whether or not you agree we have a
legitimate oversight
the fact that you're not complying with
our requests is a de facto well you're
not going to comply we have provided
almost 2 000 documents in different
forms
the redacted documents that the chairman
showed it's a little bit of a red
herring i say with respect because those
were multi-subject documents i'm
informed and where the subject wasn't
subject you know that portion of the
memo wasn't responsive to the subpoena
it was blacked out because we're
obviously not producing non-responsive
material
we are not redacting heavily the
material that the committee is seeking
and that is within its core
oversight uh arena well i with all due
respect i think this committee would
disagree with your assessment that we
have been we feel like we've been
stonewalled and we've not gotten the
information that we've requested from
doj but i don't want to take up all my
time on that line of questioning
you sat here this morning during the
hearing the second panel with the
the three special agents
did you hear them say that this was the
first time and perhaps the only time
they had seen such an operation as this
one exists i did hear them say that and
is is that of any concern to you that
out of nowhere there's this fast and
furious program that results in the
death of brian terry
it is obviously the the some of the
testimony that was provided today is of
great concern to the justice department
and that is why we are investigating it
through the office of the inspector
general and cooperating with this
committee's investigation is this the
first time you've heard any of that
testimony
i've been generally aware of it in my
role as the head of the office of
legislative affairs i've obviously been
aware of this for a number of months and
what what when you say you're generally
aware what does that mean
um
i i've i've been involved in producing
responses to letters i've been in
discussions about how to uh comply with
the committee subpoena um so i've been
aware i must say i was very pleased to
be here today to hear personally all of
the uh testimony that was provided and
and before i get on to my last question
did you hear the
issue they raised regarding retaliation
i did and i thank you congresswoman i
want to assure the committee
um i think a number of members raised
this uh that the department of justice
will not would never retaliate against
whistleblowers
lastly my question and i uh asked the
family of uh brian terry what if they
had the ability to ask a question what
they would like to know so i'm going to
read the question that mr heyer
gave us to ask you and i'd like
as to the best of your ability answer to
this question i think that we would want
to know if the dragnet that is set to
find everyone involved in brian's murder
will be set deep enough
and wide enough to encompass anyone
involved in operation fast and furious
the answer to that question is
unequivocally yes there is a firm
commitment in the department of justice
to bring everyone responsible for agent
terry's death to justice
and the second part of his question
if the guns used in brian's murder were
a part of this operation
then we'd want to know will everyone in
the operation that had that had to deal
with those specific weapons
be brought up on charges of facilitating
the murder of brian terry
obviously uh the whole purpose of the
investigations that are ongoing both in
the office of the inspector general and
here is to ensure that there is
accountability for the decisions that
have been made and and most importantly
to improve to strengthen our law
enforcement efforts if there are floored
flawed strategies if there's a
insufficient surveillance of weapons
obviously that's something that the
justice department wants to rectify
thank you i yield back mr chairman i
thank the gentlelady we now recognize
the gentleman from texas mr farrenhold
for five minutes thank you mr chairman
um
i assume
y'all are investigating various crimes
that were associated with these guns
that
aside from the tragic murder of agent
terry are there any other
american law enforcement officers or
citizens who have died as a result of
this program
congressman i i
can't accept the premise of the question
i don't know that uh
any particular murder can be attributed
to this program i think that uh assumes
a lot of uh
facts and and and i'm just not equipped
to deal with that so i i can't answer
the question because i can't accept the
premise all right let's let's talk you
heard the testimony this morning of the
agent saying that there was some sort of
strategy that we would allow these uh
guns to move up the chain of command
with the
rather nebulous goal of snaring a drug
cartel
are you aware
is this the strategy and if so can you
tell me
in any rational basis how the means that
we used justify the ends when we quit
following the guns as soon as they
changed hands the first time there was
no cooperation with the
mexican authorities and it just seems
like once they did the first top we just
went away
congressman one thing i heard loud and
clear from the atf testimony today from
those agents was that uh the people with
whom they disagreed on the strategic
questions
told them and believed that they were
engaged in a strategy to
topple a
significant transnational
gun trafficking operation if the
strategy was flawed
uh then
individuals should be held to account
and the strategies should be improved
but i did hear that everybody had the
the goal
of stopping illegal gun trafficking to
mexico well to me it just doesn't see it
seems like you the next step is you
follow the guns all the way the actions
that appear to have been taken don't
seem to make any relationship to the
strategy
at all but i've got a couple other
questions so we're going to we're going
to leave that on you've
been reluctant to provide information
and answer questions
continually citing ongoing criminal
investigations and not wanting criminals
to go free or jeopardize
these investigations but my
understanding i'm a lawyer my
understanding of our justice system is
that the defendant is titled entitled to
all exculpatory evidence so if we've got
something that will help the defense
we're obliged to turn it over so it
seems like that y'all i'll go ahead and
turn it over to us so we can finish our
investigation and meet your legal
obligation to any defendants in this
case for full disclosure
congressman we're certainly going to
meet our constitutional obligations to
the to the defendants um
i would note that when
the committee interviews potential trial
witnesses you're creating material
that wouldn't otherwise exist
that may be used to impeach witnesses at
trial
i mean we're after the truth and
regardless of whether it comes out in
front of this committee or comes out in
front of a trial it shouldn't shouldn't
matter
let me go on you also say that there are
some concerns with releasing information
to us it would jeopardize other
investigations and other strategies and
programs is that correct yes would you
be willing to provide a
briefing to
all or some of this committee in a
classified basis about those
i think you've sensed a lot of
anger out i'd go so far say anger from
this community this committee
that
our government is engaged in what we
perceive to be a reckless operation
even if in a classified manner you could
assure us you guys aren't so far off the
reservation that there's a problem i
think it would go a long way to stemming
some of the
for lack of a better word adversarial
conversations that are going on i hear
you congressman first of all we'd be
pleased to brief the committee we have
briefed the committee and will continue
to do so
it should not be adversarial i want to
emphasize this we
share the committee's concern
about the matters that you heard about
this morning we are not adversarial to
you in this we are trying to get to the
bottom of this ourselves and i'll yield
my remaining 30 seconds to the chair
thank you thank you gentlemen uh you
made a statement in that letter
that you signed on on the 4th that said
atf makes every effort to interdict
weapons that have been purchased
illegally and prevent their
transportation to mexico
who prepared that line in your letter
chairman i said you signed it who
prepared it was it you
these letters are the product of the
justice department so your signature on
that letter doesn't mean that you know
it to be true is that correct i take
ultimate responsibility okay isn't that
statement false
now with what you know
obviously uh there have been
allegations that call into serious
question that particular documents that
now have been provided and made public
that let you know that that statement
was false and and that's that's why
you're investigating and that's why
we're investigating i'll just take your
agreement that those documents indicate
that that statement that you signed that
someone prepared for your signature were
false
congressman i'm not prepared to say that
at this time everything that we say is
true to the best of our knowledge at the
time we say it as more facts come out
obviously our understanding of the
situation is enhanced
just for the record we will be posting
online the 20-some pages that were made
available
since out of the 20-some pages the only
thing that's not redacted
other than internal use-only statements
is
kevin simpson acting division operations
officer u.s department of justice atf
201 east
washington street suite 940 phoenix
arizona and the zip
the phone numbers are redacted
that's a hundred percent of what you
call discovery would the ranking member
like a second round uh i just have one
question
gentleman's recognizing just just
following up on
what you just was talking about
let me ask you this mr weiss again i
want to go back to trying to
be effective and efficient
um
again we we
i'm tired
of
when
when we're in put in a position where
we're wasting time
um
you know we may be
dead
next week
so
i'm just be very frank with you i'm
tired
i don't want to waste time
life is short
this is the question
if
you got assurances the department got
assurances
that we would
not be
uh
disclosing documents that are extremely
sensitive
and
agrees to uh you know to try to make
sure
that
when we would commit to
working out accommodations where
um we could go through i mean you submit
the documents
we go through them making sure that that
and we sort of go through them together
and come up with some type would you be
willing to come up with some kind of
schedule whereby
we can get what we want you can be
assured that
we're not doing something that
uh interferes with the kinds of things
that you just talked about we we will
work with you congressman we strongly uh
favor that kind of cooperative
accommodation process it's traditional
and in this instance where we recognize
the committee's legitimate oversight
needs we
want to lean into that process
and do as much as we can to provide
information to them well would you all
be willing to commit to a schedule a
document production schedule
see see this this is what i'm getting to
we we can do this all day
and a new congress will be in
um and that's why i'm talking the way
i'm talking i i'm we got to get stuff
done
and
i can't we cannot keep our commitment to
miss terry
by doing this back and forth thing
um it's a waste of time
it's a waste of effort
and life is short i hear your congress
so
i'm trying to get you to
which i'm trying to help you help us
i understand and hopefully help yourself
at the same time
so
i mean if we can work something out can
we move past this yeah we
because obviously the majority feels
like we're not moving fast enough and i
can understand that
that you're not moving fast enough i
know you got me all kinds of i think he
has
said something like 700 000 pages or
something like that
more than okay
what would you suggest well let me put
it another way how how what kind of
arrangements would you suggest that so
that we don't keep
running into this wall
i don't think we've hit a wall i don't
think we're at an impasse i think we are
now on track i i obviously it may have
been a bumpy start but we have produced
documents in each of the last three
working days we made a witness available
for an interview and we have a list of
others we're ready to facilitate
interviews of
we are
doing what i think you're asking
congressman which is trying to
accommodate the committee's needs
consistent with our confidentiality
interests well would you after this
try to sit down with us and try to see
if we can't i mean it's up to determine
he's the chairman's committee but see if
we can work out something where we can
get
our documents and set up a schedule so
we can get these documents faster the
last three days is wonderful but i think
we need to try to see if we can move the
process along a little bit i'd be
pleased to do that i would welcome that
uh one thing i would say is we've
devoted substantial resources attorneys
full-time to review these documents
we've hired a contractor to help us put
these in in a form that they can be
efficiently reviewed so where we're
rolling here you know one of the things
one of the problems here is something
that i talk about a lot
is and i recommend this book to you it's
called the speed of trust by covey
and he just talks about when people
don't trust each other
it slows down everything
when they trust each other it speeds it
up and i think maybe we need to i know
you you all are worried about
documents being released
seems like we're worried about not
getting all the documents timely
sometimes type of way we got to break
through that so that we can do the work
of the american people and with that
i yield back
i thank the gentleman and all i'll close
uh
or uh
more patiently than i opened
the uh
would you uh agree to voluntarily
provide a list of doj or and or other
personnel that prepared or participated
in the preparing of the february 4th
letter that we've had so much discussion
about
congressman i'm not prepared to make
that commitment at this time these
letters are uh the product of
substantial deliberation within the
executive branch as i said would you
agree to make available a list of
personnel
who worked on and may have in some way
been responsible specifically for the
misstatement
in the letter that says atf makes every
effort to interdict weapons that have
been purchased illegally and prevent the
transportation of mexico i'm not
prepared to make that commitment at this
time what i am committed to to what i'm
prepared to commit to is an ongoing
effort to help the committee get to the
underlying questions here about uh atf's
law enforcement activities
now just for the record
your job
the reason
you're paid and and basically have the
title you have is to answer congress's
questions
that's a big part of my job roughly five
months ago senator grassley was told by
your office in writing that he wasn't
going to get answers because he wasn't a
chairman
you're aware of that right i am well i
mean that's not an accurate statement i
mean if i may respectfully or more
specifically it's not that he won't get
the chairman leahy would have to request
them we we have answered senator
grassley's letters we have great respect
for senator grassley with whom the
department has worked on many projects
over the years quite productively um as
to oversight it is the long-time
position of the executive branch through
administrations of both parties that the
congress each house of congress speaks
through its committees as to oversight
and so you are exercising the power of
the house no senate chairman has made a
parallel request and i'm well aware that
for two years of this administration
there were no republicans able to make
those requests and have them granted and
the requests generally were not made at
all
uh that is in fact the position of the
majority here is that uh there wasn't
valid oversight for those two years
uh it's my personal position and i'll go
on the record today since people were
kind enough to read things from the past
that we need to have legitimate minority
rights and that at some future time in
congress and each time the rules are
produced i'm going to try to have a
party of the opposite party of the
president even if they're a minority
have rights because i think it's wrong
that in fact the majority ultimately
often finds itself asked and encouraged
to protect the administration i was here
for the bush administration i was more
junior but i certainly saw people in
your position constantly
cajoling us
to protect the president i don't approve
of it i now appreciate just how wrong
that was
having said that uh i will on behalf of
the committee
suggest something you may take back to
doj
if you're willing to do in-camera review
100
unredacted
i repeat 100 unredacted and please don't
say it's unacceptable because it's
obviously above your pay grade
you prepare
you we come over we being the staff
they look at the unredacted material
to the extent that we can agree on
mutual redactions and the materials are
sent over
to the extent that we disagree then we
can talk in terms of con of of documents
that have been seen but are not
available are not releasable do not fall
within your concerns because i share
your concerns that our rules are such
that once something comes over here with
the exception of the select intelligence
committee it becomes
much more problematic as far as review
or release
i want to get around that i want to work
with justice on it
i cannot from this side of the dais
accept any responsibility for documents
that are leaked by third parties who get
them and i cannot
enter into a negotiation where you
tell us you're going to redact what we
got around you well you don't even let
us see unredacted uh versions in camera
there's never been a time in which i was
more animated than when my staff came
back from that breakthrough meeting to
find out that they had mostly black
pages as your response in camera so
please take back on behalf of this
member and i hope the minority
that we should be trusted to send over
career professional staff to look at
unredacted documents understanding we're
not taking them with us until or unless
there is an agreement to how they would
be appropriately redacted that is an
extension i'm putting on the record
until that occurs we will continue to
expect discovery and we will continue to
object to getting virtually all black
pages
uh with that i think the ranking member
has a question the gentleman just for a
second of course i'm assuming that the
message that you're sending to higher
ups that would include both sides
staffed from both sides
that's exactly the intention is
simultaneously it's a simultaneous uh
our policies and for those who may want
to be aware of it our policies are that
in fact anything that is received as a
document production is received to both
sides as you know
mr weish normally we ask you to send
copies to both sides simultaneously
in the case of an in-camera we would
expect that staff would be detailed from
both sides to go over and review it but
we will only come back for in-camera
review
if in fact and we'll send cleared
personnel to you know pre-agreed to from
both sides if that becomes an issue but
we have to look at the source material
if an in-camera review it will be
appropriate
no judge is going to look at
redacted material as is in camera
certainly you wouldn't expect us to see
a part of a document
that does us very little good and then
say well yes we had production well mr
chairman i appreciate your recognition
that i can't sort of negotiate this kind
of thing at the witness table but i can
assure you that we will work with you on
these kind of process concerns that's
the mode that we're in trying to help
the committee address its oversight
needs we look forward to that this has
been difficult i will go again last on
the record
that we believe that there has been some
breakthrough in the last week or so we
were thankful for the breakthrough uh
it's been a while in coming but
hopefully it's the last time that we'll
have a log jam with that and with that
this uh hearing stands adjourned
um
now available